Một thứ phang Mỹ thông báo tăng gốc đôi quan phía thuận lên tới năm 2020, trong cung cấp không tin,
dẫn từ việc bắt giữ tổng thổ quyền nên gilya Nikolas Maduro.
Hoa xinh tơn các buộc ông Maduro tham gia vụng bản mặt với và hợp tác với các mặng nhỏ tối pháp
New trend Air War và Sinaloa.
Mọi trường viên nên gilya i banguin bắt bỏ, vỏi đây là mạnh khỏi lo biết nhất từ trước tới nay
và các buộc Mỹ trên chuyển chính trị thổ thiện, nhằm học thận phía đổi lập ở viên gilya.
Mí lần đầu chào thường để bắt ông Maduro năm 2020, mất mấy làm sợ đồa Mỹ,
khi các công tổ viên lên vào Mỹ truy tổ, Maduro về tổ buồn bản mặt với tháng 1 năm 2020,
mất thường, các lấy anh làm sợ đồa Mỹ, cùng lên chúng phát mới với các quan chức tấp gào với Nizuela.
Cào dưới quan sát, quan tin chào thường của Mỹ chỉ mặng tính biểu tượng.
Bởi con bố hiểu rất đồ ở dưới Mỹ và VNizuela, khi hai nước cách đất quan hệ ngoại giao của các bạn trong mấy chiến.
Nói ra ở Maduro đã làm lạnh đạo đường nghiệp, kiểm soát vàng bộ vụ mọi quên lực và côn độ VNizuela,
vì vậy không có cơ chế pháp li hập lệ đến Mỹ có thể bắt giữ lộn này.
Tuy nhiên, tần đây Washington đã thu dữ hài truyền cơ của Maduro,
đông thời liệt trend, rw, mở nở mở nở bà và nhiều văn gòng đốt VNizuela vào vệng sách tổ trước khủng bố.